ah les vacances on en a tous besoin mais
au début des années 60 problème les
français partout tous en même temps pour
leurs vacances d'été délicieuse vacances
de trains bourret et de routes
encombrées mais bien sûr on a le droit
d'aimer ça en 1964 un record est atteint
12 millions de français sont sur la côte
en même temps au mois d'août résultat
des plages et des hôtels bondés et des
heures et des heures de bouchons sur les
routes une solution pour éviter cet état
de fait est allé ses vacances sur
plusieurs mois étalez les vacances ça y
est l'idée est là au départ ça concerne
seulement les vacances d'été en 1965 le
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme
présente le plan d'abord des vacances
scolaires différentes entre deux zones
de france a et b avec quinze jours de
décalage ce qui au total est à l' sur 14
semaines l'ensemble des vacances
scolaires pour l'ensemble de la france
le zonage fonctionne alors on le
généraliser aux autres vacances
scolaires d'hiver de printemps et il
s'élargit
le deux zones on passe à trois en 1971
c'est aussi au début des années 70 que
la pratique du ski s'ouvre aux classes
moyennes ces trois zones sont donc une
aubaine pour les professionnels de deux
semaines de vacances il passe à quatre
semaines et peuvent accueillir beaucoup
plus de touristes mais dans les années
80 l'organisation change plusieurs fois
trois zones de zone ils ne savent plus
où donner de la tête à peine les enfants
se sont-ils habitués à leur nouveau
calendrier mis en place l'an dernier
déjà le gouvernement le modifie pour la
rentrée prochaine retour à la carte
scolaire à trois zones d'un côté on veut
éviter que les français soient tous en
vacances au même moment de l'autre les
professionnels du tourisme font pression
pour allonger les périodes de vacances
et puis les parents d'élèves eux veulent
qu'on respecte le bien-être des enfants
trois zones
nous ne sommes pas contre pour permettre
à plus de jeunes de partir en vacances
mais le faire d'une manière anarchique
sous la pression de l'or blanc et parce
qu'un ministre n'a pas été capable
d'empêcher quelques embouteillages alors
je crois que c'est se fiche des intérêts
des enfants au sens propre depuis les
années 90 les vacances des français sont
rythmées par ces zones à b et c dernier
changement en date en 2015 les zones
scolaires sont modifiés et les vacances
de printemps sont avancés pour le plus
grand plaisir des stations de ski les
vacances de pâques se termineront au
plus tard le 1er mai 2016 résultat un
troisième trimestre très chargé pour les
élèves les moins chanceux devront
travailler on semaine d'affilée avant
les grandes vacances d'été les zones de
vacances scolaires un sacré casse tête
depuis près de 60 ans
[Musique]